last night's Grammys brought out the
biggest stars in music and Beyond and
gave us a true fashion piece and joining
us from Vancouver for the TMS breakdown
we're going to unpack all the triumphs
the misses and the so-so historical
choices here's Susie wall all right
Susie we got a lot to get through so
let's get right to it and we've divided
all of the outfits that kind of caught
your eye into different categories that
have been inspired by last night's
nominated and winning songs and albums
correct it was such a visual Buffet so
much to get to your right Jeff this is a
it was a big night there was a lot to
talk about so let's Dive Right In with
nominated hit song Brian Adams so happy
it hurts this inspires our very first
category stars who dressed for Success
there was a lot to look at on the carpet
last night let's begin with cardi B and
I think we got Taylor Swift in there
with her too these two women look
phenomenal cardi walking walking the
carpet like sort of an astronaut afraid
to move this look this look walked the
runway in Paris just a few days ago and
then Taylor on point Midnight's wearing
you know the the oh I love the long
sleeves the crop the midnight blue the
big earrings there were both triumphs
for me how about you guys oh completely
completely for all the reasons you just
mentioned yes absolutely so on point
cardi I can't get enough of her next
step let's go to Steve Lacy I was
obsessed with this custom Saint Laurent
I think he arrived wearing matching
outfits with his mom which just so
amazing the brooch the the clutch he was
like a sports car and then Adele looking
so phenomenal she looks so happy I
wanted to be at that table with her and
lizzo this is kind of Ruby velvet Louis
Vuitton phenomenal sculptural
architectural gorgeous a complete 12 out
of 10 for me both triumphs yeah again
Jeff what about you and Steve Lacy
that's a Triumph
right I was trying to be dramatic and
just hold it there for a second let's
see this is bad okay next up I think we
have oh maybe Beyonce the queen giving
new meaning to arriving fashionably late
you guys she missed accepting her first
award she was stuck in LA traffic I
thought she'd wear some gigantic Queen
kind of headpiece but instead we got the
rose gold bustier the beautiful metallic
ruffle skirt she was a Triumph for me I
just thought she would take it even
farther over the top but still
phenomenal exactly
okay moving into our next category
speaking of Steve Lacy his next this
next bucket is inspired by his hit song
and nominated song Bad Habits so these
are kind of like these Stars keep going
back to the bad fashion well in my
opinion this let's begin with Stevie
rexa Barbie core you know Cara has been
having a moment I love pink she's a
gorgeous girl uh I would have rather
seen her in like a gorgeous red lip
maybe a Hollywood bombshell side part
and a black rock and roll dress this was
too much for me Machine Gun Kelly and
Dolce and Gabbana looking very Jiffy Pop
but I liked that he was talking about
how he was feeling anxious on the carpet
he showed some vulnerability there I
thought that was really cool but for me
come on they both missed are you guys
with me or no oh no I'm good yeah not
yeah just both okay maybe I'm in a bad
mood on this Monday morning moving into
Harry Styles kids song
as it was beginning with of course Perry
so these are looks that were very retro
that caught our eyes no matter what and
you know what Harry walked that carpet
all the oxygen was sucked off of it when
he arrived he forgot his shirt I love
this Swarovski kind of Patchwork
jumpsuit thing he had going on I love
that he chose to wear a performance
outfit Mona skin such a Rolling Stones
cover for me they said they're
influenced by everybody from Fleetwood
Mac to Metallica wearing Gucci I thought
they were out of the park these were
both triumphs for me you guys oh yeah
okay those outfits just scream Grammys
to me yeah exactly and this carpet's no
joke the smell of aerosol and body spray
and body paint when you're on this
carpet is quite shocking okay next up I
think we have Pharrell in a retro kind
of MJ throwback studded quilted
tracksuit he was matching with his wife
the two on the right for those of you
who don't know them this is Damian and
JD back they're kind of like emojis for
me they're both Musical prodigies I
don't think I'm smart enough to get
their Vibe plucked off the internet they
are a smash runaway hit right now and so
hot but I'm not loving it so I'm giving
them both so so's interesting
oh wow you're on either end of the
spectrum yeah one Triumph one miss yeah
okay uh Pharrell's the triumph
or well I've interviewed him he wasn't
very nice to me so he only gets a so-so
otherwise Pharrell if you'd been nice to
me bro you wouldn't you would have
gotten a Triumph and I'm a huge Morel
fan and I love his wife Helen stylus and
designer and of course just all-around
bomb Viva so I do think they're super
cool so Props to them sure these next
Stars take us on a bit of a good or bad
you know it's been a visual Journey so
we're gonna begin with our Canadian
sweetheart Shania Twain did you guys see
Shania walking the carpet there she is
caricature and next stem Smith so
beginning with Shania for me two
caricature ish she was inspired by Harry
who's inspired by her Dan Smith I love
that he was bringing the Unholy hit song
The Life lace fail the top hat the
gloves I get his kind of Gaga Entourage
thing which I didn't love because I
think he can stand on on his own
absolutely but what did you guys think
because for me Shania was a mess and oh
interesting oh look at us
I love me Shania I know okay I think by
the way
a total Triumph by the way I love it
when people take chances it's a total
track unless you happen to be sitting
behind either one of them at the Grammys
with those hats
and that's a miss you missed the whole
thing then I'm going from Triumph to
miss if I'm sitting behind you you're
exactly knocked my hat off next up we
have MJB Mary J Blige the queen walking
the carpet she's 52 skin bearing Swagger
the Hoops the crystals the platinum and
there's Liz though Dolce and Gabbana
gape and count Tangerine or gown and
tape brother I don't know if it was
rose-colored or Tangerine bright orange
I thought she looked amazing with the
rose embellishments to reveal sort of a
beautiful corset gown underneath so for
me I'm gonna say Mary J was so so and
lizzo was a Triumph I wanted Mary J to I
wanted her hair to be a little different
I wasn't happy with her beauty but yeah
both gorgeous women I love them both
okay moving on to our next speaking of
lizzo her hit song it's about down time
oh yeah yeah these are fashion comebacks
so people who have maybe not quite found
their fashion pudding yet so let's begin
with the lovely Kelsey ballerini I
thought she looked sweet and adorable
and she's young right she's still kind
of trying to find her footing but I
thought this look was on point I love
the cutouts I love the yellow and
there's Doja cat no body paint no
bikinis you know no gimmicks just vinyl
glove and gown that's what we all think
to wear when we're being kind of right
down Main Street right for me they were
both a Triumph I'm totally there with
you they were saying they could steer
Dojo walking the vinyl moving down the
red carpet okay I think we have a shot
of Coco James but I'm not positive about
that one no I think we're moving into
our next category okay this is Adele Uh
inspired by easy on me of course the
Love Ballad The Breakup album so good
this is fashion with little effort yes
so people that kind of mailed it in so
this is the Grammys right Omar Apollo
one of our first dudes this is and
you're nominated in like Best New Artist
or something these are this is your time
to emerge and there's Omar on the on the
left he's wearing just like a leather
jacket he looks like he's going to I
don't know 7-Eleven he was wearing a
pair of jeans and an open shirt he was
with his family very sweet guy there's
Jack Harlow on the right looking a
little bit bank robbery had a pair of
black gloves on that I would have loved
to see tone with the rest of his outfit
for so for me these guys are both a mess
this was a big chance for them this is
the music Olympics and I think they
missed it so so Carolyn like a true
mother defending the boys I get it I get
it
yeah I thought they could have used like
uh a pop of color maybe right yeah oh
look at the fashionista
pocket square yeah I get it I hear you
okay so last up um Beyonce's break my
soul the hit song This inspires our next
category these were kind of fashion
flops for me
um you know fashion Trailblazers in
other eras but last night maybe didn't
quite make it over the Finish Line let's
begin with Jennifer Lopez so she was
there with Ben there she's gorgeous she
looks amazing but there was just too
much going on with this Gucci gown the
chandelier earrings the Ruffles The
Fringe the necklaces it was just too
much Carolyn I can't wait to see or hear
what you think of this look and then
Dwayne The Rock Johnson for me this
color was like really why would you pick
this color and his necklaces and he's
wearing a camisole I love it when guys
wear a good camisole but it's a strange
decision for the rock I would rather
have just seen a bare chest underneath
that look and the two of them together
it just didn't work for me both a Miss
I'm sorry I love them both stew oh
interesting job
so I can't wait two misses to Triumph I
was I was like I was pondering but you
sold it you sold me Susie when I take in
J.Lo's full look I don't want the hair
down when all that is going on and to on
top of everything so and I'm with you at
the right with the rock so I'm I'll go
with Miss okay listen I'm going Triumph
because uh JLo can do no wrong and I'm
not going to be the one to tell but
Rockies and Miss okay
so much fun so good to be with you guys
all right thank you Susie appreciate it
as always Susie wall with her Grammy
fashion wrap for us and coming up next
here on the morning show total trying
always yes